Son circuitos muy interesantes de la médula de los vertebrados
que pueden generar, por sí mismos,
patrones rítmicos de actividad, muy coordinados
y al mismo tiempo reciben solo señales de entrada muy simples.
Y estas señales de entrada
provenientes de la modulación descendente desde partes superiores del cerebro,
como la corteza motora, cerebelo, ganglios basales,
modularán la actividad de la médula
conforme nos desplazamos.
Lo interesante es hasta qué punto solo un componente de bajo nivel,
la médula espinal, junto con el cuerpo,
ya resuelven una gran parte del problema de la locomoción.
Quizá ya lo sepan porque al cortar la cabeza a un pollo,
este puede seguir corriendo un rato.
Eso muestra que con la parte inferior, la médula y el cuerpo,
ya se resuelve gran parte de la locomoción.
Pero entender cómo funciona es algo muy complejo
porque, en primer lugar,
grabar la actividad de la médula es muy difícil.
Más fácil es implantar electrodos en la corteza motora
que en la médula espinal, por estar protegida por las vértebras.
Sobre todo, en humanos, es muy difícil de hacer.
Segundo, la locomoción se produce gracias a una interacción muy compleja
y muy dinámica entre estos cuatro componentes.
Así que es muy difícil averiguar el papel de cada uno en el tiempo.
Aquí es donde los biorobots como Pleurobot y los modelos matemáticos
realmente pueden ayudar.
Entonces, ¿qué es la biorobótica?
La biorobótica es un campo muy activo de investigación en robótica
que quiere inspirarse en los animales
para hacer que los robots salgan al aire libre,
como robots de servicio, robots de búsqueda y rescate,
o robots de campo.
El gran objetivo aquí es inspirarse en los animales
para hacer robots que operen en terrenos complejos:
escaleras, montañas, bosques,
lugares donde los robots todavía tienen dificultades
y donde los animales se desempeñan mucho mejor.
El robot puede ser una gran herramienta científica también.
Hay proyectos muy buenos en los que se usan robots,
como herramienta científica en neurociencia, biomecánica, hidrodinámica.
Este es exactamente el propósito de Pleurobot.
En mi laboratorio colaboramos con neurobiólogos
como Jean-Marie Cabelguen, neurobiólogo en Burdeos, Francia,
y queremos hacer modelos de la médula y validarlos en robots.
Queremos empezar de forma sencilla.
Es bueno empezar con animales simples
como las lampreas, que son peces muy primitivos,
y luego, gradualmente pasar a animales de locomoción más compleja,
como salamandras,
pero también a gatos y humanos,
los mamíferos.
Y aquí un robot se convierte en una herramienta interesante
para validar nuestros modelos.
Para mí, Pleurobot es una especie de sueño hecho realidad.
Hace más o menos 20 años yo ya trabajaba
haciendo simulaciones informáticas del movimiento de lampreas y salamandras
durante mi doctorado.
Pero siempre supe que mis simulaciones eran solo aproximaciones.
Como simular la física en el agua, o en barro o en un suelo complejo,
es muy difícil simularlo correctamente en la computadora.
¿Por qué no tener un robot real y una física real?
De todos estos animales, uno de mis favoritos es la salamandra.
Podrán preguntarse por qué y es porque, dado que es un anfibio,
es un animal clave desde un punto de vista evolutivo.
Establece una relación maravillosa entre nadar,
como vemos en la anguila o el pez,
y la locomoción del cuadrúpedo, como vemos en mamíferos, gatos y humanos.
De hecho, la salamandra moderna
se parece mucho al primer vertebrado terrestre,
por lo que es casi un fósil viviente,
lo que nos da acceso a nuestro antepasado,
el antepasado de todos los tetrápodos terrestres.
La salamandra nada,
haciendo una marcha de natación anguiliforme,
para ello propaga una onda viajera de actividad muscular de la cabeza a la cola.
Y una vez en el suelo,
pasa a un modo de andar al trote.
En este caso, se produce una activación periódica de las extremidades
muy bien coordinadas
con esta ondulación estacionaria del cuerpo,
y es exactamente la marcha que están viendo aquí con el Pleurobot.
Pero muy sorprendente y, de hecho, es fascinante,
todo esto lo puede generar simplemente la médula y el cuerpo.
Si tomamos una salamandra sin cerebro,
no es tan agradable pero se le quita la cabeza,
y le estimulamos la médula con electricidad,
con un bajo nivel de estimulación inducirá un modo de andar similar.
Si se estimula un poco más, la marcha se acelera.
En un momento, hay un umbral,
y automáticamente, el animal pasa a nadar.
Es increíble.
Sencillamente cambia la marcha,
como si pisar el acelerador
de la modulación descendente en la médula espinal,
cambiara por completo entre dos marchas muy diferentes.
De hecho, lo mismo se observa en gatos.
Si uno estimula la médula de un gato,
puede pasar de caminata, a trote, a galope.
O en las aves, uno puede hacer que pasen de caminar,
en un nivel bajo de la estimulación,
a batir alas en un nivel alto de estimulación.
Y esto demuestra que la médula espinal
controla la locomoción de forma muy sofisticada.
Por eso estudiamos la locomoción de la salamandra en más detalle,
y tuvimos acceso a una máquina de rayos X muy buena
del profesor Martin Fischer de la Universidad Jena en Alemania.
Gracias a eso, tenemos una máquina increíble
para grabar el movimiento de los huesos en gran detalle.
Así hicimos.
En esencia, descubrimos qué huesos importaban
y recolectamos su movimiento en 3D.
Recolectamos una gran base de datos de movimientos,
tanto en tierra como en el agua,
para obtener una base completa de los comportamientos motrices
que puede tener un animal real.
Nuestro trabajo como robotistas fue replicarlo en nuestro robot.
Mediante un proceso de optimización encontramos la estructura correcta
para colocar los motores, para conectarlos,
para poder reproducir esos movimientos lo mejor posible.
Y así cobró vida el Pleurobot.
Veamos cuánto se asemeja al animal real.
Aquí ven una comparación casi directa
entre la marca del animal real y la del Pleurobot.
Puede verse que hay casi una reproducción uno a uno
de la marcha a pie.
Hacia atrás y poco a poco, se ve aún mejor.
Pero todavía mejor, podemos nadar.
Para eso usamos un traje seco y recubrimos todo el robot...
(Risas)
y entonces podemos ir al agua y reproducir la marcha de natación.
Aquí estábamos muy contentos porque esto es difícil de hacer.
La física de interacción es compleja.
El robot es mucho más grande que un animal pequeño,
por eso tuvimos que hacer un escalado dinámico de frecuencias
para asegurarnos de lograr la misma física de interacción.
Pero al final, logramos buena compatibilidad,
y estábamos muy, muy felices.
Pasemos a la médula espinal.
Con Jean-Marie Cabelguen
modelamos los circuitos de la médula.
Lo interesante es que la salamandra
conserva un circuito muy primitivo,
muy similar al de la lamprea,
ese pez parecido a una anguila primitiva,
y parece que, durante la evolución,
surgieron nuevos neuroosciladores para controlar las extremidades,
para lograr la locomoción de las piernas.
Y sabemos dónde están estos osciladores neurales
pero hicimos un modelo matemático
para ver cómo deberían acoplarse
y lograr esta transición entre las dos marchas tan diferentes.
Y lo probamos a bordo de un robot.
Y tiene este aspecto.
Aquí vemos una versión previa del Pleurobot
totalmente controlada por nuestro modelo de médula espinal
programado a bordo del robot.
Lo único que hacemos
es enviarle al robot mediante un control remoto
las dos señales descendentes que debería recibir normalmente
de la parte superior del cerebro.
Y lo interesante es que, jugando con estas señales,
podemos controlar completamente velocidad, rumbo y tipo de marcha.
Por ejemplo,
si estimulamos en un nivel bajo, tenemos el modo caminar,
y, en un momento, si estimulamos mucho,
muy rápidamente pasa al modo nadar.
Y, por último, también podemos hacer giros muy bien
con solo estimular más un lado de la médula que el otro.
Y pienso que es realmente hermoso
cómo la naturaleza distribuyó el control
y le dio mucha responsabilidad a la médula espinal
para que la parte superior del cerebro no tenga que ocuparse de cada músculo.
Solo tiene que ocuparse de esta modulación de alto nivel,
y es trabajo de la médula coordinar cada músculo.
Pasemos ahora a la locomoción del gato y a la importancia de la biomecánica.
Este es otro proyecto
en el que estudiamos la biomecánica del gato,
y queríamos ver en qué medida la morfología ayuda a la locomoción.
Encontramos tres criterios importantes en las propiedades,
básicamente, de las extremidades.
El primero es que la extremidad del gato
se parece más o menos a una estructura de pantógrafo.
El pantógrafo es una estructura mecánica
que mantiene el segmento superior y los segmentos inferiores siempre paralelos.
Es un sistema geométrico sencillo que coordina un poco
el movimiento interno de los segmentos.
Una segunda propiedad de las extremidades del gato: son muy livianas.
La mayor parte de los músculos están en el tronco,
muy buena idea, porque las extremidades tienen baja inercia
y pueden moverse muy rápidamente.
La última propiedad importante es el comportamiento tan elástico,
para manejar impactos y fuerzas.
Así diseñamos Cheetah-Cub.
Invitemos a Cheetah-Cub al escenario.
Este es Peter Eckert, que hace su doctorado sobre este robot,
y como ven, es un pequeño y lindo robot.
Parece un juguete,
pero se usó como herramienta científica
para investigar estas propiedades de las patas del gato.
Como ven, es muy compatible, muy liviano,
y también muy elástico,
de modo que podemos pisarlo y no se romperá.
De hecho, saltará.
Esta propiedad de ser tan elástico también es muy importante.
También se ve un poco las propiedades
de estos tres segmentos de la pata como un pantógrafo.
Pero lo interesante de esta marcha bastante dinámica
es que se obtiene exclusivamente en lazo abierto,
o sea, sin sensores, ni bucles de retroalimentación complejos.
Y eso es interesante porque significa
que la mecánica ya estabiliza esta marcha bastante rápida
y que la mecánica realmente buena ya simplifica la locomoción.
Al punto que incluso se puede perturbar un poco la locomoción,
como verán en el próximo video,
podemos hacer algo de ejercicio, pedirle al robot que baje un escalón,
y el robot no se caerá,
lo cual nos sorprendió.
Hay una pequeña protuberancia.
Esperaba que el robot cayera de inmediato,
porque no hay sensores, ni bucle de retroalimentación rápida.
Pero no, sencillamente la mecánica estabilizó la marcha,
y el robot no se cayó.
Obviamente, con escalones más grandes y con obstáculos,
se necesitan bucles de control total, reflejos, y todo.
Pero lo importante aquí es que para perturbaciones pequeñas,
la mecánica es correcta.
Y pienso que este es un mensaje muy importante
de la biomecánica y la robótica para la neurociencia:
No hay que subestimar hasta qué punto el cuerpo ya ayuda a la locomoción.
Ahora, ¿qué relación tiene esto con la locomoción humana?
Claramente, la locomoción humana es más compleja que la del gato y la salamandra,
pero al mismo tiempo, el sistema nervioso de los humanos es muy similar
al de otros vertebrados.
Y, sobre todo, la médula espinal
también es el controlador clave de la locomoción humana.
Por eso, una lesión en la médula espinal
tiene efectos dramáticos.
La persona puede quedar parapléjica o tetrapléjica.
Y eso debido a que el cerebro pierde la comunicación
con la médula.
Especialmente, pierde esa modulación descendente
para iniciar y modular la locomoción.
Por eso, un gran objetivo de la neuroprotésica
es poder reactivar esa comunicación
mediante estimulaciones eléctricas o químicas.
Y hay varios equipos en el mundo que hacen exactamente eso,
especialmente en la EPFL
mis colegas Grégoire Courtine y Silvestro Micera,
con quienes colaboro.
Pero para hacerlo correctamente, es muy importante entender
cómo funciona la médula,
cómo interactúa con el cuerpo,
y cómo se comunica el cuerpo con esta.
Es ahí donde los robots y los modelos que presenté hoy
espero que jueguen un rol clave
en esos objetivos tan importantes.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Auke, he visto en tu laboratorio otros robots
que nadan en contaminación
y miden la contaminación mientras nadan.
Pero para esto,
mencionaste en tu charla como efecto secundario,
la búsqueda y el rescate,
y tiene una cámara en la nariz.
Auke Ijspeert: Por supuesto, el robot...
Se desprenden algunos proyectos
en los que quisiéramos usar robots para inspección de búsqueda y rescate,
por eso este robot ahora los está viendo.
Y el gran sueño es, si uno atraviesa una situación difícil
como el derrumbe o la inundación de un edificio,
y es muy peligroso para el equipo de rescate o incluso para los perros,
por qué no enviar un robot que pueda arrastrarse, nadar, caminar,
con una cámara a bordo, que inspeccione, identifique sobrevivientes,
y que quizá haga de enlace de comunicación con los supervivientes.
BG: Claro, suponiendo que las víctimas no se asusten por su forma.
AI: Sí, probablemente deberíamos cambiar la apariencia un poco,
porque supongo que un superviviente podría morir de un ataque al corazón
por temor a que esto se lo coma.
Pero cambiando la apariencia y haciéndolo más robusto,
estoy seguro de que podemos lograr una buena herramienta.
BG: Muchas gracias. Gracias a todo tu equipo.